my high school Glendale High School
today we're gonna surprise my old health
and guidance teacher Kim Cinco she has
no idea what we gonna do about the
surprise so this is the AP psychology
class my name is Patrick bit David my
birthday is October 18th 1978 I am all
to you 36 years old so I sat in this
seat is where I said right
same seat with the girl whose fathers
birthday's on October 18 right and rumor
has it John Wayne also said it was I
don't know if you know John when the
celebrity John so if it's not a rumor
we're creating that rumor today 22 years
ago and we still are in touch today
oh yeah Kim was a major like during the
army she was a major in the army
and when I was 14 I was not clear about
my life like many of you maybe I was
very unclear about what I wanted to do
my life so she was the reason why I
joined the army I went into the army
because of her when I got out of high
school and straight to the Army look at
the kim sinclair changed my life changed
my life my encouragement to all of you
would be to drop out of high school
to leave and get a get a job and these
teachers have no clue what they're
talking about we just wanted to make
sure you knew that so you have the
opportunity if you leave home today you
don't come back it's ok everyone we're
giving you a hard time you don't have to
freak out the reason why I came out here
today if I can have my friend come in I
don't think this happens enough times
but we wanted to stop by Tim bring you
some flowers bring you some the today's
message is very simple going in and out
of class in just 20-some years ago that
was me and you don't really know who's
gonna make an impact in your life I
didn't know it's a 14 year old kid mr.
Clara's gonna inspire me to join the
military get my act together come out
and be a value to society and the
inspiration credit goes to her
challenging me to consider the military
because she didn't see me as somebody
that had a 4.0 GPA that I could go on
apply an application to us UCLA or
whatever we're now gonna been expected
accepted by them so today's message is
simple gratitude is so powerful and
sometimes with our everyday busy lives
that were living we forget how much
different people I touched our lives
make a list of them but to meet today's
message is more directed towards
teachers make a list of a teacher that
made an impact in your life send them a
gift send them some flowers
Cicero once said gratitude is not only
the greatest of virtues but the parent
of all others I think it's important for
us to remember how much of a role
gratitude plays with our friends family
mentors people who have impacted our
lives
it's my message a week to um please be
sure to subscribe to this channel and
comment on the bottom